Oh welcome everyone to Q&A time with
PewDiePie for some reason you guys like
these thank you god I hate these stories
I don't care
stop posting them anyway I post them on
asking you guys to ask me questions so
let's go
obviously there are new sources that you
don't agree with or like but are there
any you actually recommend of course
this may be controversial I think
there's definitely a couple that are
good but I think there's an underlying
issue with most of them where it's as if
journalists jobs functions the same way
as it is for youtubers where they're
paid for clicks on their articles so
they're highly motivated to get more
people to read their article and that
leads to a lot of clickbait it leads to
a lot of hot takes and it makes me
wonder what happened to journalism when
it used to be subscription-based so yeah
they didn't have to rely on these
tactics that being said why did we as an
audience care about any of these sides
anyway just because they have a new
website we give it some sort of voice of
authority when in reality most people
don't seem to care anyway so I don't
know it's that it's like even sometimes
when there's a hot take on a website
that no one's heard about but you see
that it's a news website so you're like
oh my god this is so stupid but in
reality is like it doesn't matter I
guess my point is I'm over it I don't
care no that's not true but I hope
people will be as well what are your
future goals after YouTube implying
there's gonna be an after YouTube do you
think YouTube will exist let's say I
have a career until I'm 60 or 65 do you
think YouTube in 30 years is still gonna
be the biggest platform for video
content it's not impossible but it
doesn't seem that likely that YouTube is
just gonna be the top website forever
and if I keep making videos for that
long time I don't I don't think it
matters I found on YouTube or not on
YouTube I think what matters more is if
I still want to make videos at that
point which I don't know the answer to
where do you see yourself 20 years later
okay here's the question I don't know do
you do anyone know that I think I just
realized who I am as a person and I am
very into the things I like to do I
right now I still really like to do
YouTube but I also think I have a lot
more to give
which
sounds very naive I just feel it myself
that I am capable of more things than on
what I'm doing and sometimes I'm worried
that I'm trapped to make the same daily
kind of videos and not working on bigger
things and if I'm not sure if that is
holding me back or if that's something I
should just keep pursuing why are you
talking much about politics in the last
month I don't think I have have I how do
you motivate yourself when you don't
want to do something but you have to get
it done write down a list that's always
the best thing whenever I think I'm
stuck and I know I have things to do and
I'm procrastinating I always write it
down a bullet point list of the things
that I need to get done today and that
way you can start chipping off the easy
bits and then you can get a clear
scheduling your head on how you're gonna
make that done make a video make a
thumbnail prep the video prep tomorrow's
video answering emails work out read go
home or practice Japanese there you go
that's what my day looks like which
youtuber was the most fun to collaborate
with I think I have the most fun when I
record with Jaken
and Ken because we are actual genuine
friends obviously it's really fun to go
outside and collaborate with random
people it's the kind of thing where as a
youtuber you're benefited to network
right
you're Bennett it's beneficial to reach
out to people that you wouldn't normally
engage with just as a way to broaden
your scope of Brandon and all that but I
find out to be very I don't like
networking I think it's dishonest and
tri hardy and gross in general what's
your actual net worth you've hinted it
being higher than Google says and what
do you do with that money do you have
invested in stocks or bonds could you
give us a brief overview what you do
with your money right now it's very
messy because I'm set up in Sweden and
UK so I have like four or five companies
I have some invested in stocks and bonds
but I think overall I don't really spend
it on anything personally because I
don't like having things around me I
find it very annoying I think media
likes to undervalue 8 me now after I
became more controversial like in the
Forbes top list I know I'm higher than a
lot of other youtubers on that list but
they always seem to put me lower now and
that's why I'm saying like it is bigger
but at the same time it doesn't matter
who cares it's so unimportant I don't
know I don't know what's important to me
I don't it's not money it's really not I
think money for people is like an inch
people want it because they don't know
what it's like to experience it and then
you have it and you're like actually I
feel the same way now when you retire
from YouTube would you consider founding
a network something so other youtubers
can reach their dreams like you well
surprise I used to have a network with
Disney called rebel blood and that was
the idea I realized that there are so
many ways that I can create a company or
do all these things but I don't care
it's boring I have the dream job right
making YouTube videos is what I sign up
to do because I want to do it for me to
go into other businesses would be a lot
of time commitment and very boring as
I've learned it's extremely boring
compared to YouTube you you have to want
to if you want to pursue a business
separately and I've already made money
so there's no incentive to be honest I
feel like a lot of times like a
hypocrite because I keep saying I don't
like care about money but I'm obviously
still generating a lot of money I'm
still selling merch
I'm still putting mid rolls in my videos
I'm still doing sponsors and it's like
if I don't care about money why do I do
these things in a way it feels like
you're validating your work by making
money I know that maybe not makes sense
at all then again the way you make
youtube videos and how successful you're
channeling is ties in to how you're
making money as well if your video makes
a lot of money YouTube is going to
recommend that video more as well does
that make sense I hope in 2019 I can
start living by my own ideals more does
that make sense
what's something you wish YouTube would
change anything you'd like to see come
back put me back in Google preferred
YouTube that reminds me actually I think
that's why I got so caught up with I'm
looking I'm looking at myself now but I
can understand why I want to make more
money because of what happened in 29 at
2017 2017 when the Wall Street Journal
article came out my show was canceled I
was kicked out of Google preferred
getting Brian deals was so much harder
you know they didn't want to touch me so
I wanted to prove okay well you know I
don't need to work with big brands I
don't need to be a friendly friendly
brand to make it and to still earn the
same living so I have to be you know I
wanted to show that I could do that and
that's why I worked myself into that you
know I got to work with a lot of cool
opportunities still like clutch is one
of those companies that were actually
loyal to me even though all that stuff
happened and I think that's that's
really cool and other brands as well
that I'm really happy I can work with oh
yeah I think it's gotten to a point
where it might feels a bit much isn't it
why don't you collaborated videos with
markiplier anymore I think our content
swayed in different directions people
seem to think there's beef between us
that's not it at all
it's literally just I think we probably
have a mutual respect for each other but
we don't have that kind of relationship
where we have to collaborate to maintain
anything I don't know it's like a if you
don't interact with someone online
that means you hate each other that's
how people perceive it online the way
the audience perceives relationships and
how it is in real life is completely
different from reality and I understand
that's hard to understand maybe but it'd
be great if people aren't blowing all of
it up for no reason okay
what were the hardest and best moments
of your YouTube career and now have you
always enjoy the content you make well
I'll start with the first one I think
both for those things happen this year
best moment was obviously the wedding
and I got to share that on YouTube but
also some of the hard has happened this
year as well and it's mainly stuff that
I've had to sort of dealt with behind
the scenes a lot of things that just it
becomes more complicated if you dress it
online basically but that can also be
very frustrating because my whole the
whole way I've dealt with things on this
channel has been I talk about it I
address it and I get support from my
audience when I do it and that's the way
for me to deal with a lot of hardship
that comes with YouTube and then
transfer have I always enjoy the content
I make it goes up and down I think in
general when I find myself not enjoying
what I make that's when I tried
different things and based on you guys
what you guys think of it I go in
different directions and that's the fun
of YouTube I think that's why it's
always changing for me and I'm not doing
the same things all the time
how long do you plan on doing YouTube
I've been getting this question so much
all the time because yeah I said I was
gonna go on a break and because things
are sort of wrapped up for me almost you
know I got married I hit 100 million you
know it would be a good time to just end
it on the high and it's kind of annoying
almost how people keep asking like as if
as if I should quit like when are you
quitting are you thinking about it maybe
you should do it I love YouTube and I
think I have more to give I know that's
kind of naive to say but I generally
think so and I sometimes I question
whether you know if it's possible for me
to achieve more by the format I'm doing
now since I'm uploading every single day
and if it has longevity in the sense of
I don't really have days off right now
this year has just been extremely busy
it's been the busy year of my life and
I've already had extremely busy years
before where I practically broke down so
I hope I can find better balance for me
to keep doing YouTube if every year was
like it was this year then no I would
not do it for very long
what makes you so interested in Japan
culture or Japan in general it's like
people think you're a we've just because
you like Japan anyway it's like the
least thing that interests me about
Japan obviously their culture is so rich
and it's so different from the West and
I think a lot of their values and and
way of interacting fits in with me as
well it's hard to just point at one
thing and say this is what I like when
it's a lot a lot a lot of different
things do you still have the same
passion for making videos as you had 10
years ago had his reduced or increased I
would say it's is pretty much the same I
think there was more excitement because
there was so much more growth in the
beginning and you go from from nothing
to something big in a time but in
general I still really like it because I
think I'm still pushing myself to do
different things I've been doing like
this philosophy type of videos and more
of a different style that I'm not used
to and that's beginning a lot of good
feedback so that makes me excited to try
out different things so I am how was
emergency I doing can you guys please
record another try not to cranes
challenge together you guys are a couple
girls a lot watching you both being in
love watching and love love laughing
together and bring us all a smile - is
doing great I think she did quit YouTube
to kind of leave YouTube and she
definitely wouldn't mind being in a
video but I I don't really want to drag
her into that hemisphere
and I understand once he left that you
don't want to be be back into it that's
how I would feel at least if I left
youtube I wouldn't want to keep being
hey guys why don't you play horror games
again pewds I do play if there's a
horror game that's out that's
interesting I think I played as someone
amnesia mod recently and it was like the
worst performing video I've done in
forever so I know there's some people
that want something but in general you
look at the bigger picture and it's like
I'll do it from time to time if I feel
like it but in general it feels like
something I've already done once you
play enough horror games you understand
the premise you understand the whole
thing and it becomes a bit redundant I I
do it mainly as a way for nostalgia at
this point it's kind of like as if I
went back to play happy wheels all of a
sudden it's just merrily F for the sake
of nostalgia and it has no it has no
value in itself it's just repetition
which kind of bores me a little bit
serious question how does constant media
coverage both positive and negative
affect your well-being
I imagine having your friends family
stumbling upon one of your the countless
articles written about oneself must be
taking a toll on anyone's mental half
after so many years stay healthy
everyone mental well-being I don't think
it affects me if it has they would have
done in the past it's something in
general it's like you cross a line and
it's like it doesn't matter you just
realize it doesn't matter I think in
general they're just digging their own
grave at this point and it's just a
matter of time where there's gonna be a
whole new generation that don't believe
in their credibility anymore do you see
people taking photos in secret
yeah it happens all the time one of
Polish youtubers said he took a photo of
you when he was in UK because he didn't
want to disturb and I wonder if you see
people do that and what do you think
about it it's extremely cringy it
happened actually when I was in Italy
now some guy did this and then the flash
went off and I'm just like really and
then they don't even go oh and the worst
part is afterwards they go up I'm like
hey can we do four I'm like you just
took a photo it's super cringy I hate
the fact that people look at me like I'm
some sort of attraction I'm a person
like everyone else and I want to be
treated like a person I don't think
that's too much to ask
hate the whole culture of I'm so tired
of it and that's why I said if you meet
me what you have to say is is math
related to science because that's how I
know if you're a cloud chaser or if you
or if you're a genuine 19 year old the
way people react what I found in
different countries is very different
right if you go to countries like
Malaysia and Singapore people are very
hectic and screamish and crazy and they
lose their mind if they see you and they
do all these crazy stuff and and then
you look at countries like when I go
back to Sweden people are more like me
more reserved very polite and calm and
just and and more I would say a lot
nicer about it which I really really
appreciate so that makes me think the
whole way people react isn't just like a
natural reaction of being nervous it's
just like a trained reaction of okay so
this is I'm so how I'm supposed to act
if I see a famous person so me
complaining about it isn't like that I'm
fed up with it it's more like I want to
change it I love meeting fans don't get
me wrong but I also want people to just
treat me normally as well and I don't
like when people scream I don't like
when people get freaked out and I
understand you get excited that's not
what I'm talking against I think there
is like a culture to to treat people
like they are more than they are and
that annoys me but to answer your
question take people taking fun in
secret yeah that's rude and annoying and
it's cringe as hell because I can see it
a lot of time happening where do you see
YouTube in two years from now will they
actually listen to the community anymore
or will they turn entirely into an
advertiser flavor platform that doesn't
care about community I just demonize all
borderline content it seems that they
are making steps to improve towards edgy
content I've seen them do that with with
advertisers YouTube does have to face
with a lot of reality with the reality
of backlash that comes from the media
that is inevitably going to affect their
advertisers that is a difficult position
to be and to sort of look at the bigger
picture but then at the same time you
have a website that's for creators but
the crater's needs advertisers
I wonder if YouTube just had the balls
to just stand their ground how that
would affect it because they are they
are essentially a monopoly I will say I
think I it's obviously complicated and
in a lot of ways I
I understand YouTube but at the same
time I think they made decisions in the
past that are so anti youtuber that I
wonder it's gonna take them a lot to
come back to a better point with the
community I think and I think if YouTube
wants to have longevity even if they do
have monopoly they need to get that back
nothing is forever you know
that they could easily become another
website in the future I don't see that
as an impossibility at all you've taken
up many many other passions beside
YouTube such as making video games what
would be another passion you would like
to take up I think music could be fun to
work with I know that's the really
cliche that's like what a lot of
youtubers do but I think it could be a
fun medium for me to express a lot of
ideas and thoughts that it's hard to put
into words in a video I think music
could be an interesting medium to do
that
will you make more philosophical videos
like that I hate Twitter video yeah I
will definitely make more I have some
stuff I'm being then I sort of just let
it simmer in the back of my mind
whenever I feel like thinking about
something so I just make it when it
comes natural light I try not to force
it how do you deal with a lot of hate
alone well I think the important bit is
to understand that everyone is a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
no I yeah sorry it's making me laugh
because it's it's I'm joking but it's
also true but only because you also have
to be honest with yourself and see okay
if someone says something then it's
making me feel a little uncomfortable
because maybe there's some truth in it
then I think it's important to address
that and you said as constructive
criticism but I think once you get
something that is just purely stupid
with no logic behind it or constructive
feedback behind it then yeah I treat
everyone like they're an idiot we should
a lot of people art I swear in the
internet it's like the smartest and
dumbest thing ever I don't remember if I
answered it this way but if you could
change something this year what would
would you change if anything definitely
try and find a better balance between
work and time off what do you like so
much about Japan that you are moving
there is it being able to walk around in
public without getting recognized
there's a lot of things that I like
about Japan it's definitely not only
that but that's definitely a plus it's
one of the few Asian countries where I
can actually move around and
get recognized which is very liberating
because every time you meet someone they
just want something from you they want
that picture if I can't draw the
distinction if they're a genuine fan and
if they're just someone that thinks
you're famous that's kind of
soul-crushing in a way where are the
kids Felix oh boy
so for years and years and years people
have been pressuring me and Marcy to get
married and now we finally did and where
are the kids
god it's so annoying I wish people
didn't ask to be honest because it
pressures it should be come from us and
it shouldn't come from pray like I don't
want to be pressured about it it's like
no stop it's like I say the smallest
thing like oh we're going I'm taking a
break and people like it's gonna make
baby or like I don't know if you had the
choice between amnesia and minecraft or
what would you pick well minecraft
obviously do you think your content get
better or worse compared to let's say
2017 do you think you try more or less
when making a video compared to that
time I probably try more because the
videos kind of have to be a little
longer now so it does make it a little
bit more complicated before you can just
record like 10 minutes and cut it down
to a five-minute video I think the main
thing I noticed with all the videos is
the voice my voice is so different like
how's it gone Brad
hey how yeah it's just so cringy to me I
hope I finally find a voice that is
actually my voice open 21 I look back at
now and I don't cringe yeah I don't know
why you look depressed for real please
tell us why do I look depressed no I'm
not dony
so weird I think mainly I'm just
frustrated I think so much happened this
year that I didn't take time to process
and that's also part of reason of this
break I think how did you overcome video
awkwardness and what was your motivation
when you started making videos that's
funny how you mentioned that cuz yeah it
was very awkward to make videos the
first time you do it it's like a weird
thing to speak into a microphone or a
camera it's not normal it takes practice
just keep doing it and you'll get over
it my motivation was to just create my
own path and find something that I liked
I felt very trapped doing what something
that I didn't enjoy
I think I'm extremely fortunate to have
broken out of that the fact that I was
able to turn YouTube into a
question was was my dream it's still is
I'm so happy I can do a job that I
genuinely enjoy doing I think the only
thing like this to summarize this whole
video it's like I love making videos but
being at the precision I am it's way
more than I bargained for I hope things
can just simmer down a little bit
simmer down and next year I can take
some time to fully process a lot of it
as well and that's it for this Q&A hope
you guys enjoyed listening to me
rambling about
booooo-whoo my left so hard and that's
it bye bye hey
[Music]
the hour of our spells and poop grades
is coming
marzia Edgar and buckells need you
the timer you will face but crawlers is
all about
when you are seated on the porcelain
throne Bertie is the game to play I'm
not supposed to have my opinion about
that but the prizes
[Music]
you